[Music]
good boys raided our what sorry we just
were doing how to kiss Lucas there's
another business we should have just
told the truth we're going to a kissing
party and none of us have ever kissed
then we're scared
damn Lucas I've had sex before but I've
never kissed a girl look can you please
have the drone back if you don't give it
back I'll tell my dad you stole it
and I'll tell him that you're a pervert
we'll tell the whole school this is
sensual harassment well tell everyone
that you're a misogynist never massaged
anyone this is what happens when you
don't respect women I respect women my
mom is my best friend
good boys hold it
come here what do you have your pants my
penis
pull it out dick
put it back I'm being generous today we
also have drugs it's on to us okay what
do you have schedule 1 controlled
substance with intent to distribute
brother these are vitamins ok children's
vitamins up there no those are drugs
no that's drugs and this is drugs too if
you don't arrest us I'll report you ok
[ __ ] alone and he's already [ __ ] swear
of kids but [ __ ] you no I'm gonna arrest
you for a [ __ ] living Monday all
right I'll take them let me go home he's
going for Becca what do we do hello
listen I decided I don't want kids
the cops I [ __ ] this have to make a
run for I know what to do well no I'm
just up from the sky well yeah no you
may be detective but in the marriage
were equal well hang up his freedom
good boys raided our I didn't get ready
struts I'm just gonna throw them in the
stream they can contaminate the water
and then we could throw it in the forest
it's a sex drug what if a fox eats it
and tries to [ __ ] a squirrel it'll kill
him then how do we get rid of drugs the
same way we get rid of a baby a
possession no drop it off at the fire
house on our way up to the mall that's a
really good idea it was spread off for
strong crude sexual contact rocket
alcohol
good boys rated R don't come any closer
why cuz you could overpower us so put
the drone on the slide and count back
from 100 and close your eyes and don't
try anything funny bear witness timeout
crackheads tools off we can't let them
put drugs back on the street
look at those dirty [ __ ] junkies
their lives are already ruined let's
just give him the drugs and get the
drone maybe there's a way we can protect
our community and get the draw back
stall them so what do you plan to do
with those drugs huh take them and feel
amazing Jetix yeah so you've been
drugging your whole life uh-huh
every day no nice boys read off her
strong crude sexual contact
all involving tweet
you